with the world churning virtual cyber
attacks are constantly flooding new
headlines covid-19 accelerated the
current digital transformation in the
year 2020 witnessed several data
breaches since technology has become
more intertwined with our daily lives it
is no surprise that the need for skilled
cyber Security Professionals is
increasing on that note hey everyone
welcome yet to another exciting video by
simply learn which will take you through
the top cyber security career options
available today but before we begin if
you're new here and haven't subscribed
already make sure to hit the Subscribe
button and that Bell icon for
interesting Tech videos every day
there is a significant lack of skilled
cyber security professionals who can
tackle the cyber security challenges
faced daily hence a career in cyber
security is demanding and equally
rewarding finding the right career path
in the cyber security industry isn't
always easy here we are here to help you
with that there are a few prerequisites
for a career in cyber security the basic
one being a bachelor's degree in a
subject relating to cyber security
however if you don't have a relevant
degree you can always take up relevant
cyber security certifications and
Kickstart your cyber security Journey
a few other skills like networking
knowledge of operating systems and Cloud
security are required to start and grow
your cyber security career you can check
out our video on the top 5 cyber
security skills to know more
cyber security jobs vary from entry
level to Executive management and
everything in between there are several
cyber security paths available today it
is best if you start with entry level
and then move on to the next level with
the help of certifications and relevant
experience here let us have a look at
the top 5 cyber security job roles today
the first job role is that of a network
engineer Network Engineers construct and
administer a company's computer networks
they are responsible for installing
configuring and supporting Network
equipment they also configure and
maintain firewalls switches and routers
this entry-level cyber security job can
help you start your journey to become an
ethical hacker the annual average salary
of a network engineer in the US is 85
000 and 98 dollars and in India it is
around 510 000 rupees
second on our list is information
security analyst a some information
security analyst your primary duty is to
protect sensitive information
information security analysts create and
Implement plans for preventing cyber
attacks they monitor data access and
ensure compliance with policies
depending on the Cyber threat they
decide if it has to be resolved or
escalated further in the U.S an
information security analyst earns eight
to nine thousand and one hundred forty
dollars annually and in India they earn
6 lakh 42 and 756 rupees
third in our list is ethical hacker they
are also known as penetration testers
they are Network Security Consultants
who identify and exploit system
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do vape probe and test and network
using various penetration tools and
software they also design new
penetration tools and document the test
results in the US a certified ethical
hacker earns around ninety three
thousand dollars on an annual average
basis and in India they make around five
lakh rupees
the fourth job role that we are going to
talk about is security architect
security Architects research and plan
the security elements for their
organizations they design robust
security structures that are capable of
preventing malware attacks a security
architect approves the installation of
routers VPN and firewalls their duties
go beyond just architecture building and
including formulating company procedures
guidelines and user guides security
architects in the U.S make a handsome
sum of 124 000 a year on an average and
in India they make nearly 21 lakh 80 000
rupees
and finally fifth on our list is Chief
Information Security Officer ciso they
are senior level officers in an
organization they ensure the safety of
the information they develop Implement
and maintain information security and
risk management programs they also
interact with stakeholders and regularly
brief them with information security
concerns the average annual salary of a
chief information security officer in
the states is a whopping 165 thousand
dollars annually and in India it is 22
lakh 22 and 845 rupees several companies
are looking for skilled cyber Security
Professionals Philips Siemens Google
Microsoft NGE to name a few with passion
the right amount of experience and
relevant certifications you can grow
your cyber security career you you can
check out Simply learned cyber security
expert Masters program to equip you with
the necessary skills needed to become an
expert in this rapidly growing domain
this course will help you learn various
methods as to how you can protect your
infrastructure secure your data run risk
analysis achieve compliance and much
more so with that we come to the end of
this video on the cyber security career
I think we missed anything important do
let us know in the comments section
below thank you so much for being here
and do watch out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here